you might have seen Salvation Mountain
music videos or in documentaries it
attracts people even for folks who
aren't religious this hill covered in
half a million gallons of latex paint
and sitting in the middle of the Sun
blasted California desert this Hill has
something about it and it was the work
of just one person the other night was a
man who whose cattle lost the screws
around trying to figure out what to do
he discovered Jesus so he had a mission
and then he started doing things and he
made a hot-air balloon
you know like 200 foot sold it all
together with all these praises to God
on it brought it out here you know the
desert ended up taking his toll on the
balloon but he stayed and he built this
mountain you really have to look at it
to get the big picture that Sand Hill
that way shows exactly what was here a
couple of little straggly bushes and a
flat with hill sand and let her built
all this he added extra clay hay bales
whatever it took to build this all up
you know he just kept going and going he
was gonna dome the whole thing off and
he never really thought of himself as I
already more thought of himself as
somebody just do and what he was doing
he was a persistent dude this mountain
originally fell after three and a half
years of building he rebuilt he wanted
you know he had a passion and this is so
beautiful twenty-eight years of
dedication try dedicating 28 minutes or
something nowadays realistically I think
about that Leonard Knight had no
training no collective of other folks
around him the technical term is
outsider art he wasn't inspired by
anyone else's work and bless you count
God he wasn't imitating great artists he
wasn't asking for feedback from friends
around him he just created this and it
resonated with the world years after his
death there's a group of people here who
give their time preserving his legacy so
we have so many people coming from
everywhere I've met people from little
countries in Africa to all over Europe
to do floating little islands and this
and that it's amazing you know and some
people they come here
you know for the religion all deals on
it cool some people come here for pretty
people taking pretty pictures at a
pretty place which to be respectful and
that's cool too you know it's getting
you all you're doing stuff they're
getting off their couches and getting
off away from the TVs and stuff which TV
is awesome too though so I'm not
knocking TV paint donations that we get
here most of them come from the visitors
they'll bring a couple of cans a couple
of cans turn it into a hundred cans
let's say I wanted to paint that heart
I would have to wait a considerable
amount of time until I had enough really
beautiful red to mix up to paint that
heart and then it makes it so much more
satisfying when you do do it but the
best thing is the art paint comes really
from the heart from the people even if
it were to fall apart it's inspired so
many people filmmakers pilgrims and
tourists alike but it'll live on in
memories in photographs and yes in music
videos the moment I knew about it I
wanted to come here and see it for
myself
I started volunteering here because I
realized that how important it was to
everybody that came here and so I
volunteered more then eventually they
had me be like a greeter and I would get
it out of that then I was like well can
I paint well I agreed I'd oh yeah go
ahead add it out uh next thing you know
I'm the caretaker and I've been living
here a year and a half in my heart I'm
the preservationist of this place I've
tried to paint it all the same and make
it beautiful and keep it you know when I
fixed it I fixed it good if I can't fix
it good don't fix it yet leave it alone
leave it alone - you can do it right the
biggest thing is this is about love
Lennon's love was God in his
relationship with Jesus but all kinds of
love is awesome like these people all
just love cruising around and hanging
out you know doing stuff that's all
makes everything better no we don't
think about all the dumb crap in this
world and you know what then the dumb
crap in this world really becomes dumb
crap in this world it doesn't have a
powerful voice there's not many places
in this world where it's good and
nothing's expected of you we hope you
would donate money to us because that's
how we do it but if you don't cool we
got free souvenirs anyway and there's
constantly stuff going on but if you
show up on like a Saturday you get to
see what this is really about it's just
packed with people having a good time
respecting the mountain respecting each
other it's awesome some folks would say
it's divine inspiration some folks would
be a bit more cynical and say that it
had to be someone of all the millions
perhaps billions of people who ever
tried creating art with no experience
and no training
yes t't istic lee someone was going to
hit the jackpot but it's difficult to be
cynical here so I've brought a couple of
cans of paint along as part of my own
pilgrimage because as it turns out I
want to help preserve this as well
you